hello I'm Isabel Kumar and I'm from
euronews and on behalf of our channel
and our partner debating Europe I'm
delighted to be with you for the first
ever YouTube interviews with the
European Commission President
jean-claude Juncker who joins us in the
studio table Jun would you please
lovely to see you so you've delivered
your State of the Union address and you
talked about topics such as investment
security and defence amongst others of
course how do you think that went down I
don't know and that's not my main
concern I was saying what I was saying
hoping that others would take over the
message and the message was that we have
to deliver on concrete issues not only
poems but also concrete measures and I
have the impression that at least the
majority of the members of European
Parliament and beyond deaths of the
European press have got the message
message well we've got a different
challenge in store for you today we've
got three YouTube creators they're
waiting in the wings they're raring to
go
they're over there they've got lots of
questions for you they've got hundreds
of thousands of followers who sent in
questions to the last time this was done
was with US President Barack Obama and
he didn't know the questions in advance
neither do you so hopefully they'll be a
few surprises
I don't like prepared interviews that's
great because our first youtube creator
is Jonas now
yonas let me tell you a little about him
he's 19 years old he's got more than a
million followers on YouTube he's even
published a book about his experiences
and he's from Germany now let me guide
you over to Eunice yeah that's good
Morgan good Ken's early on yeah good
morning
delighted to meet you I'm happy to meet
you too yeah Kyle Falcon vine can I just
take off my jacket it's very hot in
Brussels at the moment yes yonas is my
name and I have a one-off opportunity to
interview the you Commission president
and put a few questions to him which are
of interest not just to me but also to
you out there I have have not an
opportunity to put some questions about
EU policy and about EU in general and
you will be indeed speaking on behalf of
the European community thank you very
much for giving me this opportunity now
you know that I work a lot with social
media
my first politics is not business yes
but of course you do deal with politics
on a daily basis I'd like to know what
you feel about social media often I'm
not a very close follower of the social
media I have to say I don't have the
time sometimes I do take a look at
what's happening a lot of things there
are things I like because you can read
what people are thinking and there's a
lot I don't like in fact because the
kind of stuff that you get there
sometimes which is miles from reality
social media of course reach huge
numbers of people particularly young
people and that's a very good transition
to my next question gives me the
opportunity to put a couple of questions
for you and we have two other youtubers
from Poland and France would also like
to take this opportunity we'd like to
know why you see a need now to get
through to so many young people I've
always acknowledged the need to do that
what we're doing here not it is your
idea not mine but as an excellent idea
I'm really happy to be here and be able
to talk to you and a lot of other young
people not just young people of course
but to be in direct contact with people
in general this is a unique opportunity
I think indeed this is a very good
opportunity and we hope to get through
to many of you out there and we hope
that your questions will get the answers
you want next question the European
Union the EU is something that's rather
hard to get here your your head around
if we learn a lot about it in school and
we had to learn off the lists of Member
States
yes but it's part of the
school but I think I'm probably like a
lot of young people and in the same age
group we wonder what the EU actually
does and that's what I'd like to ask you
could you give us three good reasons why
we young people need EU okay the first
reason I think is not something that
would occur to young people straight off
that's a question of peace in Europe I
mean my father who died in August was
obliged to serve as a soldier in two
world wars so he experienced in his own
way
the lack of Europe or the absence of
Europe and this is something it's very
important for his generation now my
generation not directly involved in war
knows that this is not a normal state of
affairs you've got a forty different
wars across the globe at the moment none
in Europe if you exclude for the moment
what's happening in Ukraine so basically
it's it's about peace first of all
secondly it's about the future this
dilemma war peace as I said in my
discussions with a lot of young people
that's not something that too familiar
with it's a question of the future at
the beginning of the 20th century and
that was only yesterday really there
were 20% of the world population which
were Europeans or who were Europeans now
sorry 7% and very soon it'll be only 4%
4% of the global population with the
European 4% of 10 billion I mean we're
already the smallest continent and our
population is shrinking in relative
terms that applies to the global economy
and that's falling continually under
dramatically so the idea that the
reaction to this would be that the
European national states should try to
assert themselves individually is just
crazy we've got to unite our forces
not because we want to be against the
Chinese the Indians the Americans but
rather because it's a question of in
dealings with the outside world not just
economic power but also to be able to
transmit European values and that
applies to young people in particular
because they are growing up in this
world
I mean basically I'd be long gone when
there are fewer Europeans but I'm still
very very worried about that the fact
that Europe needs to maintain its global
position you asked for three reasons
didn't you okay well I would add that
there are a lot of people who don't
think in this way Europe doesn't just
have a task in terms of peace economics
work and jobs in the continent but also
it's got a global task now as long as
this is the case Europe must continue to
make an effort but the idea that five
hundred thousand seven thousand children
die every day because they don't have
enough food to eat I mean as long as
that's the case basically the Revenge of
those who don't have enough to eat would
reach us some days off that question
which is often crops up in there in the
networks a lot of Member States you have
the single currency but when it comes to
adopting children or homosexual marriage
that is matter for each individual
Member State so we just wonder why there
are some fields where it is decided by
each member state individually I mean
basically if you look at the European
treaties they do talk about family
issues as being a matter for the
national member states but in questions
of this type I am very much in favor of
being responsible I was Prime Minister
in Luxembourg and I remember bringing a
draft law into the Parliament to
legalize marriage among homosexuals
because I felt that the time had come
for this to happen
sexual discrimination of the basis of
sexual orientation cannot be permitted
whether we're talking about homosexual
men or women who love one another that's
one of the nicest most beautiful things
in the world why should states prohibit
people from loving one another are
coming together I've never really
understood that so I'm very much in
favor of respecting all people one
shouldn't I think be so arrogant as to
assume that you can impose a policy
you've got to like people and love
people in many kids that's I think a
very encouraging vision my next question
concerns a rather unfortunate topic
terrorism this unfortunately now it
affects Europe and we've seen some
shocking pictures from France and recent
times these have affected young people
and they wonder whether as EU citizens
we need to have to be afraid of
terrorism be afraid of being affected by
terror cetera attacks what is he you
doing there have been 30 terrorist
attacks in Europe since 2004 14 of these
last year some of the worst of course
occurred in France and here in Brussels
I mean so there are a lot of innocent
victims I don't know if there any other
kind of victims but to a large number of
people lost their lives and that means
that the member states of the European
Union do have to move closer together
information which is available in land
in country a must be passed on to
country B we've got to enhance the
protection of our external borders we
are doing this and this will become
operational by the end of the year all
of the legal work has more or less been
completed we need to know who's coming
to your undated who's leaving Europe and
why they are coming to Europe and why
they are leaving Europe we need to know
more
not too keen them the idea of of the
state intervening in every little
element of people's private life it's
question of the influence the state has
on individuals private spheres and
intimacy I'm not too keen on that
because part of Europe is respecting
people's privacy so we need to know at
the same time who is coming to Europe
and what the reasons this is not prying
by the state in any way it's a question
of protecting the citizens as to your
question whether Europeans should fear
terror if it's our task to ensure that
they fear this less then we've got to do
just that
yes I understand it next completely
different refugee policy this is quite
controversial in Germany and the rest of
Europe in your speech yesterday you were
saying that people need to show more
solidarity and this should come from the
heart a lot of people are having very
positive outlook on this which i think
is very encouraging they want to help
they want to be active my question is
how can an individual how can you help
refugees I know a lot of people hundreds
and indeed thousands of people in
Germany and Luxembourg and elsewhere who
have made the issue of refugees a very
personal issue for themselves a lot of
young people between the ages of say 15
and 22 who have taken on board refugees
at home I very much admire this it's
it's not I mean it's not a normal
situation it's not certainly something
you can take for granted
I would like to see young people in
particular become very very committed
and speak up on this very few people are
aware of the fact that Europe has been a
continent of immigration if they look at
mcdonnell's you've got more McDonald's
in America than in Ireland or England so
basically it means that we have spread
across the globe and I think we were
happy that we were
welcomed and received and allowed to be
included in their societies and helped
to develop their societies I mean you
you absolutely got to remember why
people are fleeing this is something you
see in the social networks as well as
well as in the political discussions the
the implication that basically all all
refugees are terrorists or one cannot
avoid the fact that there will be some
terrorists among the refugees which is
why I said we need to know who is coming
to Europe and why but I would like to
see to experience the warmth the warm
hearts of a lot of young people a lot of
people have shown this basically we're
talking about a radical battle against
radical extremism this is something
which has always thrown us back this
extremism which needs to be fought not
only with military means and by means of
words but if you want to combat populist
the extreme right rather than just
following them and repeating what they
say you've got to put them in the corner
and say to them what exactly are you
trying to say you know if you were in
the position to say well what would you
do if your children were being bombed
and your houses were being bombed day
after day would you just sit there and
wait until a bomb falls near it would
you not also attempt for the sake of
your children to do something and to
move somewhere else and the fact that so
many people are coming to Europe and we
can't deny that this does create a
problem for Europe but this is also
linked to the fact that for the rest of
the world Europe is the zone where life
is best so we've got to attempt and I
think the young people have a task here
even more so than the older generation
we've got to be very very offensive in
helping these people to find protection
and you're not everybody is entitled to
protection
in Europe but those who are being
persecuted whose wives are being or
women relatives are being raped whose
children are being tortured and killed
they have a place in Europe hey yes
thank you we're all getting older of
course mr. Anker
me to see [ __ ] the question is how do
you see the EU looking fifty years from
now maybe utopian version maybe less
utopian version how do you see the you
looking 50 years well I know how it
shouldn't look that's for sure we've got
this concept taking us back to the 50s
the post-war era era the idea the
therapy union should become the United
States of Europe that's not my concept
of things we're never going to be like
the USA Europe lead lives on the basis
of its diversity its various landscapes
its national and regional cultures and
features and if you don't see this an
attempt to create a melting pot out of
Europe and integration magma is the
expression are used in Parliament the
other day basically he's not really
taking account of people's sensitivities
so she would move away from this
maximized integration concept it's not
going to happen because that's not what
people want to mean people from Bavaria
the Luxembourgers meloni ins Fleming's
they want to maintain the identity they
have at the same time they want to
create a sphere of solidarity a tighter
more robust sphere of solidarity where
people can get on together we need to
want to and strive to get on together
and I think in many ways better Europe
is is necessary what we need to do needs
to be specified and more comprehensible
and conceptual terms no nobody really
understands what's being offered and
suggested in Europe in Brussels and
Strasbourg people tend to live far away
from these places so we need to be able
to explain
you're a better but we need more Europe
and a better Europe in terms of say
common defense it doesn't make any sense
for one country to have to assume all of
your defence effort I mean look at the
American election campaign there are
hints there that the Americans are no
longer willing to provide Europe's
military defense everywhere at the same
time I'm not somebody who wishes to
speak in favor of Europe's increased
militarization but at the same time it
is our responsibility to ensure peace
and order on our own continent and then
you've got digital Europe as well I mean
once again here we are ensuring that
this comes to fruition but it's a long
process it's going to take us right up
to 2025 we want Wi-Fi everywhere we need
to have connectivity as we say in German
right across Europe to ensure that
nobody is excluded from the new
technologies and what they offer this
applies to the national member states in
the European Union we've got to be even
more resolute in combating youthful
employment which is terrifyingly high I
mean we don't want the European
continent to be the continent of youth
unemployment and this is one commitment
for your generation and people even
younger than you you may be surprised
that there are people even younger than
you if all we can promise them is that
they will have less prosperity than
their children then we're going to lose
my final question so you incur as
president of the European Commission
Urich very experienced very experienced
politician but I'm sure you make
mistakes like all people do if there are
three things perhaps that you could give
young people what they should do better
than your generation that would be very
helpful I think we've been
I'm not particularly a typical
representative of my generation or the
generation prior to yours if you like
there are quite a number of people who
could do that better than I could but
one mistake which was made and it brings
me back to a point you made earlier that
basically we tend not to like other
people I mean you're in your own country
this is a transcontinental phenomenon it
may seem to be a bit naive but I
genuinely feel that all people are equal
in terms of rights opportunities and
chances you really cannot allow
anybody's future to be cut off from them
I think we need to be more interested
Express more interest in people from
other continents Africa is a continent
which is arising if you like and it's
not just a question of charity we've got
to invest in Africa and the Commission
has made proposals very recently for
this I mean it's it's it's all very well
to have a tear in your eye when you
think about hunger and refugees and
migration but you've got to go beyond
that and actually do something this is
something which the European governments
and the European business Federation's
companies and so on also need to do they
need to invest in Africa and I think
that's something which will shape the
future very important today thank you
very much for co-occur thank you for
answering all my questions I'm sure
there are a lot of other questions as
well
but you've given us a very interesting
answers thank you very much we
appreciate it I've got again well if you
would just stand here that was a great
discussion this is our turnaround yes
there we go
if you just move that way so that was a
great discussion I think you covered so
many issues past present and future
along with our partner debating Europe
we've asked our online audiences to send
in questions to using the hashtag ask
Yongkang now one topic that yonas didn't
bring up that you discussed obviously in
your State of the Union address was
brexit and so we have a question about
brexit and that comes from Duncan and he
asks brexit was a symptom not the cause
if the course goes untreated then things
get worse so what would you diagnose as
the cause of brexit this is a simple and
an easy question good asking for
thousands of answers of course brexit
means that something is wrong in but
quacks it means also that something was
wrong in Witten if over 30 years where
is cleaning to your general public that
European Union is stupid there is
nothing worth that you have to leave
that the European Union is doing as the
membership is not and the advantages to
your populations you can't be surprised
that the day you ask people do you want
to stay or do we want to leave that a
too high number of British in this in
the case we are discussing I expressing
the view that it's better to live on
Europe has so many lies so many
half-truths
we just circulated around that one
cannot be surprised but I'm not giving
to the British vote only that
explanation and I do think that the boss
European message in this tone okay so
we're gonna go now to our next young
YouTube creator and it's the lovely
little I'll tell you a little bit about
Leticia Leticia s from France and on her
channel she likes to talk about issues
such as ecology and recycling she also
took part in a YouTube initiative
- mm - FEMA which was aimed at combating
hate speech now
Leticia is in a recreation of her little
apartment it's a ballsy dump good
afternoon president please take a seat
I'd like to welcome you to my living
room those who are looking at us right
now meet and know that this is not a
real living room but you obviously have
had a say in the decor it's pretty close
to the reality I'd like to thank you
first of all for meeting me here today
I am absolutely honored and happy
because you are at the head of Europe's
top institution and I'm very very happy
to be able to ask you questions on
behalf of my community and to represent
young people in Europe and young French
people so many thanks for welcoming my
first question is this many young
Europeans are very sensitive to the
environment and the effects of chemical
products on our health on YouTube
YouTube for example I talked about this
quite a lot because the environment I
grow up in is very important to me so
the question of endocrine disrupters is
very very important
I'm not convinced that this is not
linked to health issues on the issue of
endocrine disruptors the EU has been
working towards a ban but this is linked
to the issue of roundup as well which
could give rise to cancers in certain
people and which has not yet been banned
either so this brings me back to the
feeling I've got as a result of all this
that may be the role of the Commission
is to give us the prospect of bans which
never arrived and to allow
multinationals to continue to earn huge
amounts of money by selling damaging
chemicals so the question is this
president should we be worried how can
you reassure me by arms we're working on
these very issues among scientists views
differ on the the some of these products
the substances you mentioned I would
tend to be among those
not not necessarily we're afraid but but
you ask questions who wonder what's
happening here sometimes when one does
wonder whether the published scientific
opinions which are disseminated
worldwide whether these are entirely
uninfluenced by the major producers
major corporations so the Commission is
working on this matter and we don't take
it lightly we take it very seriously so
how can I put it I take this problem
very seriously thank you very much what
my second question is this your
predecessor in the European Commission
mr. Barroso went to Goldman Sachs this
summer personally I was struck by this
because as a citizen I was wondering
whether as his role as president maybe
he might have been on good terms with
his future employer and now that is in a
private bank basically he could maybe
have some state secrets in his pockets
and or maybe these are just doubts I've
got in my mind a lot of other doubts
true I'm sure okay these were the things
that occurred to me maybe that's not the
most important thing but on this
nomination you said in the newspaper
last hour that you didn't have any
problem with him working in a private
company because he respected the waiting
period under European law of 18 months
now I understand this but you added the
fact that the fact he worked for this
Bank could be a problem for you I was a
bit surprised and confused by all of
this I didn't quite understand I'm just
wondering why why this particular Bank
might give rise to some problems I don't
really understand well yes firstly I
think Jose Manuel Barroso is an honest
man and he's a friend he decided to join
the Goldman Sachs group after the 18
months set out in the Commission's code
of good conduct and no other none of our
member states have equally stringent
good conduct including your own country
so he did play by the rules I don't see
any major issue with his working and the
financials like I understood that but my
question was this particular Bank well
I'll come to the issue of goldman sachs
if somebody leaves a major company to
become a minister for example nobody has
a problem with that as if somebody who
was working for a company a major
international company or a major
international bank and they're very
well-paid for that if they didn't as if
they didn't bring with them all the
knowledge and know-how the reflexes that
they've developed over the years working
in the primacy nobody worries about that
but if a politician leaves the world of
politics to work in the private sector
which is completely normal in in the
United States for example where you have
a constant chewing and froing between
the public sector in the private sector
their people do ask questions about this
in Europe now personally I don't have a
problem with his working in for a
private bank but maybe not this back
Goldman Sachs was one of these
organizations which knowingly or
unknowingly contributed to the enormous
financial crisis we had between 2007
2009 approximately so one does wonder
about the particular bag that tea is
ended up working for thank you now we've
got another question very recently over
the past few months people have talked
about a lot of revelations in France in
particular whereby Luxembourg secretly
permitted multinationals like McDonald's
and Pepsi to repatriate all the profits
they had made in European countries and
to end up paying say
1% in tax when I was preparing this
entry I was a bit surprised because my
husband who was a small company pays 33%
in tax and there was a big gap between
these two rates luckily you stated that
the Commissioner was going to do what is
necessary to ensure that you give
priority to this social injustice and I
was happy to hear that but then I
wondered it may be a bit naive this
question but basically are you yourself
in the best position to be able to deal
with this social injustice nothing
personal this is not an attack in any
way but you can please do attack me if
you wish to do so no no certainly I
wouldn't do that but the question is
this somebody who was a finance
ministers of the Europe's biggest tax
haven for 18 years giving them the task
of fighting tax abuse is that not like
putting a bank robber as a policeman
well very often it said that bank
robbers and poachers are among the very
best the service our police forces but
you're referring to my country of origin
of course I'm no longer a Luxembourg
politician but this I think does show
the typical view among French people of
Luxembourg each country in reality is a
tax haven for its neighbor are you quite
sure that for example the tax rulings as
they were called that is arrangements
between Inland Revenue Services and
companies are you quite sure that didn't
happen in France I'm not sure at all
it's true that's why that's why I'm
asking you the question I think it would
be worth indeed looking into this but
what I can say at this stage is that you
won't be very happy with what you
discover if you do investigate this
closely but aside from that I am quite
convinced have been and I'm still
convinced that we need clear rules on
tax issues in your company should pay
taxes where they make profits
and that is what the commission which I
preside is trying to achieve we take
that very seriously as you will see with
the ruling on Apple in in Ireland and
other such rulings regardless of which
countries or persons may be concerned
and we will see this continue I never
made any decisions on tax rulings for
companies in Luxembourg there was a
matter for the tax administration which
doesn't mean that we didn't discuss
matters with major companies that wanted
to come and set up for businesses in in
in Luxembourg of course we had contacts
with the major international
corporations but I didn't try to exert
any influence on the tax rulings on tax
arrangements of individual companies I
think all those who have been Prime
Minister's or finance ministers I wish
they could all say the same thank you
very much for having explained this that
does throw some light on it from me and
I will certainly take you up on that and
examine the issue in the next question
has been asked by a lot of people in my
community I've got a YouTube channel
where I talk a lot about the environment
as you know it's the way the lobby's
influence European legislation in the
first question I asked you I talked
about the lobbies in the organic Lobby
but my listeners were interested in
lobbying and all the other domains as
well and they pointed out for example
that citizens who elect their members of
parliament elected members who cannot
actually vote on legislation I was a bit
surprised to see that there were twenty
to thirty thousand lobbyists in Brussels
and the industry they represent spend
millions on exercising influence Philip
Morris as an example 160 full-time
lobbyists 1.5 million Europe to organise
dinners and other such events so I'm
just wondering at least I feel that
they make this effort and it's
successful in some cases what about the
pharmaceutical industry I noted that via
various lobby groups you a commission
between 2014 and 2015 meet lobbyists up
to twice a week inevitably that creates
a kind of a working relation which is
sustained and maintained by the lobbying
groups I share a small humanitarian
Association in France and we link to
organic produce
what about citizens groups like me how
can they have the same budget and
therefore the same opportunity to
exercise influence as the big companies
which brings me to the question I want
to ask you I find it difficult to
understand or believe that the EU can
guarantee the general interest of the
people rather than the general interest
of business they seem to be walking
hand-in-hand with the latter sometimes
so do you feel that the EU can guarantee
the welfare of people or companies could
you react to that olive in general terms
I it's not one against the other
citizens consumers the major
pharmaceutical companies or other
businesses against each other but some
of the points you make are quite right
now it is true the member of the
European Parliament do actually approve
do vote laws bring new legislation to
into effect at from the beginning of the
term of office of the president
Commission
I have tried we have been setting out to
draw up a transparency registry of a
very transparent registry of lobbyists
now you mentioned that we have meetings
- two days a week with twice a week with
Bobby how do you know this is precisely
because we publish this registry it's
put in the public domain commissioners
vice-presidents president ignition
directors-general whenever we meet
lobbyists we have to divulge this to the
general public we have to say which
lobbyists we received be it in our
offices be it in a pub or a restaurant
in in Brussels because people are
entitled to know who is trying to
influence decisions
I'm not against lobbyism lobbying in
principle provided that lobbying is part
of a transparent and open
decision-making process it's fair enough
for companies our consumers consumer
organizations to put forward and to
defend their interests but let's not
forget that it's not the European budget
which provides the budget for lobbying
groups however we do provide financial
support to other lobbying groups green
organizations for example consumer
organizations the key point I think is
that Europeans are entitled to know who
has met whom on what issues so if I
imagine my position as a citizen as a
young woman we're looking at a situation
where you've got lobbyists with millions
of euro to do their lobbying and the
reply is okay you can register yourself
and declare that your lobbyists no no
that's not the way it is if I for
example meet with say a major banker I
publish that I make it clear and those
who are following these matters will be
aware of whether this business has
actually been able to influence the
decisions made the initiatives taken by
the European Commission or the European
Parliament I am strongly in favor of
transparency
and I'm not their their favorite I can
assure you I just just love it let me
just reassure you on that on that point
yes I'm dead I'm reassured I have been
reassured okay well listen I have asked
you all the questions I've got a we've
run out of time so I'd like to thank you
president for having played along with
this game yes I would love to continue
in fact yes indeed
and then who decided that we have to
stop now I think time is up and afraid
apparently I'm not sure that the
commissioners decided this the ocean
doesn't decide everything after all so
yes indeed I'll hand the flop back to my
colleague who is also keen to lead you
president many thanks thank you very
much and I hope to open see you again is
this your first interview with youtubers
yes but not my last okay thank you now
that was a very interesting and frank
discussion with Leticia now along with
your news and debate in Europe I'd like
to squeeze in a question to that we got
in with the hashtag asked Younker
because in your State of the Union
address you backed the fact that you're
very concerned that younger generations
could well be poorer than their parents
and this question touches upon that
issue and it's not necessarily a
question of poverty but also of quality
of life and this question is from lina
and he says investment doesn't matter if
people have low wages poor working
conditions and unsecure contracts how
will you ensure that European economic
growth delivers high-quality jobs the
easy answer complicated it seems it's a
competence as we are saying if national
number states that look similar to
Commission but having been a Minister of
Labour for 17 years I'm very sensitive
to this question that that's why we did
launch during the Mandate of this
Commission a broad consultation on the
pillar of social rights for work a
minimal rights for social workers I do
think that okay
flexibility is from time to time
necessary but over the last 20 years
with poison in our social relationships
nationally and from a European point of
view and that is that sometimes blind
flexibility was introduced in the labor
relations my father was a steel worker
if he had been confronted to labor
contracts having to be renewed six
months after six months so having no
security at all as far as the
clarification of the material part of
his life is concerned I would not have
been able to go to university so I'm
very sensitive to this problem of Picard
is that English precarity pre-cut you
know weak relations enterprises
companies are asking for security
workers have to same security to okay
well these are issues that gonna
resonate with our YouTube communities
that are represented here I'd like to
introduce you now to Wu cash what cash
is from Poland he conducts interviews in
his tiny he's very popular and he
conducts interviews in his tiny Warsaw
oh nice for his reputation well and also
his TEDx speech because he also
delivered a TEDx speech about going from
a dreamer to a doer well you seem to
know all about him did you know that he
met Lady gaga
nobody it was his decision anyway please
let me introduce you to Mukesh be honest
good to see you good to see you so
that's my something like new studio flat
yeah welcome the environment is changing
it with the beautiful of you yeah I so
first of all let's do some promotion can
i fuel my engine [ __ ] and then let's
do some promotion for my channel what do
you know about my talk show do you know
anything I know things I have asked
because when I meet in lobbies like
humans I want to know who the guys are
okay and now I have a clear
okay fine what you are doing thank you
so much when I publish and note about
having an interview with you
many people reacted to you with mixed
emotion what is the most common
criticism against you and how do you
react to that we are not speaking about
Poland sorry you are not referring to
the Polish situation but to the overall
gross situation I think that what is
very often opposed to the way I'm
delivering my job is the fact that I
would not speak to people that I would
be sitting here in this Palermo palace
not discussing on the streets with
people if you are Luxan that's a small
country you know yeah and that was Labor
Minister there for 17 years I was
finance minister I was Prime Minister
for 19 years if you are crossing the
streets of Luxembourg don't you imagine
one second that people are respectfully
changing the side of the street they are
coming to it you know listen Prime
Minister this is wrong this is wrong
this is from this the same is happening
it was less because I have some security
problems here but when I'm on holiday
the same is happening so I'm I don't
have the impression to live beneath the
reality people are describing the
reality to me and that's been credited
that I would do that as if I was blind
I'm not blind
can a politician admit to making a
mistake and if you were to admit making
a wrong decision what would it be that
happens often in my case not very often
that yeah often if I'm mislead if I'm
taking decisions which reveal themselves
as having been stupid or not reflected
studied enough I was saying it I hope I
had since I'm in politics one principle
if I'm changing my mind I'm telling the
public that I have changed my mind I'm
telling the public know why I was
changing her mind do you never change
your mind of course I change them are
you explaining this to your father
yes yeah my friend is German public
great so let's talk about European Union
if you can tell me how can young
Europeans influence it by taking the
floor by being more vocal by being
critical IIIi don't think that we can
really progress if everyone is saying
you're right people have to tell us what
is wrong and we havin to listen to these
people not giving in the appreciations
the judgments they are making if it has
to be done it has to be done I was never
in favor of this trick because it's a
trick to say yes to everything young
people are saying or requesting those
who are saying yes yes yes just your
excellent yeah they are not respecting
that's true young people so if you
respect someone you are discussing with
always stopping on the street telling
you have to give an honest response and
then very often the honest responses I'm
given a abrupt spontaneous reactions but
sometimes when I'm back in my off you
know it was something through in this
and that's the way I'm trying to do my
job because I'm not agitated all the
time I mean of course you cannot from
from 8 o'clock in the morning till 10
o'clock in the evening ask yourself if
you are you are ok you have to take
decisions and what can brothers do to
more to make education more accessible
but the treaties
I know that young people don't like a
reference to sweeties but that's the
world I'm living in the treaties are
reserving privileged a national
competence is when it comes to education
this is not a real European duty because
we have 28 countries we have I don't
know how many regions in Europe so many
languages so many cultures so many
colours in Europe that you cannot from a
central position decide how education
should be dealt with and organized in
different countries and regions take the
example of Spain because I don't want to
take a Polish exam they have the bus
they have Catalonians they have the
kingdom of Spain but things are very
different from one widget to the other
how can you imagine that in Brussels a
commissioner or even the president the
Commission could say so many hours for
German so many hours for philosophy so
many hours first bought so many that's
not possible so it's a matter for Member
States what you can you can do is to
organize if it's necessary in a
transporting way the academic cycle of
young Europeans we have this Erasmus
program millions of young Europeans have
been part of this Erasmus a program one
out of three young Europeans having been
trained or having been in a system in 20
system in
European company is getting a job in
that company we have till now but that's
a collateral effect 3 million marriages
concluded if I can say so between those
who were part of the Erasmus program we
would like to expand this erasmus+
programme to apprentices because it's
not only of academics it's also for
apprentices I have suggested the other
day in European Parliament to create a
core of a core of young European
volunteers because I would like young
Europeans to go outside of Europe to
discover the world to be helpful in a
solidarity approach earthquakes refugee
crisis things like that I would like us
to have 200,000 people from now to 2020
being part of that solidarity program
because I know that the youngsters are
generous the those of my generation not
not really but in some years from now I
will look back young people in Europe
they are looking to the future and those
who are in charge of preparing the best
way possible the future they have to be
in permanent contact with young people
and this Corp of volunteers is one way
how to bring the Europe into a position
of responsibility thank you I heard your
speech yesterday and you said yes and
actually I will like it and you said
that European Union is not in a good
shape yeah why is like that because the
domains where we are giving more
importance to all these divisions than
to our intersections is to wait and the
domains where we are acting in
solidarity
not numerous enough and I will change
this I would like to which the
differences the divergences between east
and west and south and north in order to
have the European Union finding backed
basic principles which were at the
origins of the creation of the European
Union that we have to move together in
the same direction because I don't think
that a nation or a state or a country
whatever it will be is strong enough to
survive in a globally complicated world
we are a very small continent the small
is by the way without knowing it because
we still do think that we are the
masters too but we are not and the world
doesn't need masters it needs
responsible actors not masters dictating
but how things should be should be done
and as we are the smallest continent we
should not invest too much in our
differences our divergence is about
trying to finds mainstream a common way
a common channel how to spin into the
direction of the next century over the
next decades we have a beginning of a
century so the next century is far away
no it's to more money let's talk about
your private life I would like to ask
you what are the benefits in private
life of having your position know
nothing or do you don't want to talk
about this no first I don't want to talk
about my private life and my intimacy
I'm trying to safeguard its actually
that's fantastic I like it no no no
because I'm not a movie star I'm not
interested in having the next Oscar by I
suppose the videos with you I think
you're a movie star just know I like
other people yeah I'm embracing and
kissing that's what you are referring to
did I kiss you
no not yet I will kiss you when the
camera is why not now okay so we know
how you ready no but my private life is
has to be run in the totally separated
way from what I'm doing as a president
the Commission and if I'm allowing
others to penetrate to insert themselves
in my private life people are becoming
confused because they don't make no
longer the same between the public man I
am at the private guy I am I like the
private guy but I don't tell you why
okay when you want to talk with some
president what do you do do you just
dial them or is there some procedure I
have the mobile phone numbers of all
those who you don't have okay but
because these things are ringing first
yeah no no I I have a direct I have to
say personal contact with my colleagues
in European Union outside European Union
I know them for some of them I know them
for the case and I'm not talking to them
like Prime Minister's or presidents I'm
normally talking that's all my were you
doing my job I have established the
personal relations sometimes which of
conflicts but nevertheless in in
principle frankly no no no are speaking
for human being to human being that's
the way to make politics in the interest
of those who are serving us but maybe
you can fix my interview with Barack
Obama man he's no longer US president
that's my hue you do you want to happen
yes of course I don't think that this
would be here it would be good idea to
have an interview with him but I don't
think that he wouldn't appreciate it if
I would chip his phone about anyone
we're gonna try later
thank you so much for the interview was
really pleasure and I would like because
porn is Poland because what because
Poland is poor he has turned the master
to those who are watching us in in
Poland because very often it is said
that young gays against Poland and all
these things I said in European
Parliament yesterday that Poland is a
great nation and Poland is a great
nation and I want to have as normal and
frankly relations as possible between
how could I say my institution the
Commission and Poland I like to publish
thank you so much great thank you thank
you so much
ok another kiss join me here I would
like to thank our YouTube creators
Leticia Jana and we'll cache ok yes and
of course my pleasure president yeah
many thanks for having been with us if
you just join me a little I'm weaving
from one corner so it's an experience
I've definitely enjoyed one we hope to
recreate on YouTube and urine news of
course but it's not over yet because if
you go to the debating your website
they're building on topics we've
discussed today but in the meantime
thanks so much for having watched us
could I make a suggestion could we have
this kind of Wednesday's hair honey but
here is debate Fiser yeah absolutely
others but I know you will be there you
you are returned but I would have liked
to have the same team if that is
possible
we're for it yeah ok I'm fine guys and I
think we need to take some selfie so
smile yeah
and it misses you up there yeah super
thank you thank you very much so we're
gonna stay here for a few more minutes
thanks so much for playing the girl